e et pour en parler nous sommes avec
georges kiejman au vif président du
mouvement république souveraine
bonsoir georges kuzmanovic merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france marine le pen
qui est donc en pré campagne c'est
emmanuel macron s'active également et il
chasse à droite oui bonsoir à écouter
oui et ça fait un bout de temps que
monsieur m'accroche à sa droite
il faut quand même rappeler ses deux
premiers ministres
monsieur philippe et mathieu castex
actuellement ainsi que ses ministres de
l'économie monsieur bruno le maire son
ex-ministre du budget maintenant me
intérieur vienne dlr donc ça fait un
bout de temps qu'ils chassent à droite
et on voit bien avec la sortie tout à
fait incroyable petite trahison de
monsieur estrosi pour son propre camp
qu'il y en a bien d'autres qui
souhaiteraient avoir un maroquin de
ministre
sous monsieur macron et qui sont prêts à
mener la même politique c'est à dire les
politiques néolibérales contre l'intérêt
des citoyens français
les politiques qui vont réduire les
capacités de l'état qui vont continuer
transfert de souveraineté
là des instances supranationales comme
l'union européenne donc tout ça n'est
pas très étonnant fait est la république
quand elle arrive on l'a vue n'a pas
beaucoup d'ancrage territorial c'est
vraiment les républicains qui s'était
démarqué lors des dernières municipales
c'est quoi l'enjeu pour les prochaines
échéances électorales
la droite est divisée semble-t-il sur un
coup de simple possible ralliement à
emmanuel macron il est possible à
condition c'est la sécurité 1 écoutez
c'est tout à fait normal que monsieur
macron et échoué aux élections
municipales et c'est bien compréhensible
qu'il s'inquiète un peu pour les
élections à venir régionales et
départementales de l'année prochaine il
faut quand même rappeler qu'il a mené
une politique qui était en compte des
intérêts des français je pense à
la réforme des retraites à la réforme de
l'assurance chômage tout ce qui fait
qu'ils aient plutôt dans l'intérêt de
ceux qui l'ont aidé à arriver au pouvoir
alors qu'ils n'avaient aucune assise
politique aucune assise locale
donc je pense à l'oligarchie financière
dont il sert très bien les intéressés
par étonnant qu'ils perdent dans les
urnes
bon il espère que il va pouvoir
continuer à phagocyter une partie de
cette droite qui a trahi la nation et
qui continue à trahir son propre camp
qui continuent à trahir le message
gaulliste ont heureusement ce n'est pas
l'ensemble des dd républicain je pense
en particulier à monsieur jules julien
aubert et sans nous devons oser la
france mais visiblement toute une série
de têtes des bulgares sont prêts à
continuer à s'asseoir sur ce qu'ils
disent être leur valeur dans l'espoir
d'avoir un post nice à m oui justement
là la clé central je le disais tout à
l'heure on l'a vu aussi avec le discours
de marine le pen aujourd'hui c'est cette
question de la sécurité c'est la
condition que doit défendre en tout cas
emmanuel macron aux yeux des
républicains
gérald darmanin d'ailleurs sa nomination
n'est pas anodine il a rappelé qu'il
allait publier les chiffres de
l'insécurité tous les mois désormais ça
va se jouer sur cette question la
sécurité selon vous bon je pense que ça
va se jouer sur la question de qui va
recevoir quel poste ministériel mais
certains font semblant de s'intéresser à
la sécurité malheureusement chez red
bull gain aussi sous sarkozy on a
supprimé des postes de police plus de
7000 on manque de policiers depuis cette
époque là et ces gens là quand je lis
ces gens là ça peut être des gens qui
viennent des républicains du parti
socialiste et qui ont tous trahi leur
cause originelle pour rejoindre la pluie
comme marché emmanuel macron ne
s'intéressent pas réellement la sécurité
des français car il faudrait pour
assurer la sécurité des français
évidemment que des policiers améliorer
leurs conditions de travail améliorées
les locaux dans laquelle
avoir plus de moyens pour la justice
plus de place dans les prisons mais pour
cela il faudrait un investissement
d'état et cet investissement d'état
implique de s'opposer aux restrictions
imposées par bruxelles alors tous ces
gens là sont parfaitement d'accord pour
ne jamais s'opposer aux restrictions
imposées par bruxelles
donc tout cela c'est de la poudre aux
yeux c'est à lui de faire semblant de ne
dire que on se rallierait si tel ou tel
morceau du programme était respecté en
fait ce qui intéresse ces gens là c'est
tout simplement de loges leurs intérêts
personnels mais ils se désintéressent
totalement des intérêts des français et
de la france alors on le voit à l'image
ans il ya françois baroin notamment un
qui était pressenti en tout cas pour
pour se présenter il a refusé de
commenter aujourd'hui une éventuelle
candidature à la présidentielle
les républicains doivent trouver une
figure un ténor
selon vous c'est essentiel au delà de de
l'ancrage d'un parti politique c'est
vraiment la figure politique qui prime
dans ce genre de bataille dans la vème
république la carnation la figure
politique prime bien évidemment mais ce
n'est pas tout la figure politique est
assise sur un programme et des gens qui
vont la servir or le problème principal
des parties des ex partis dits de
gouvernement que les publicains et le
brad est socialiste
c'est que macron met en place de manière
accélérée ce que eux mêmes ont fait
pendant que de 35 ans donc c'est un
changement radical de ligne qui doit
être fait aussi bien pour les tendent à
gauche que pour être dans la droite
et s'il y avait un dirigeant républicain
je suis républicain digne de ce nom et
ben ils regarderaient un peu les mêmes
rires relierait les mémoires du général
de gaulle de gérer de gros louis et et
peut-être qu'il trouverait ce que veut
dire servir la france serbie allait
français je vais citer très très très
loin et je salue monsieur baroin qui a
sauté la case président de la république
ou
très hautes fonctions au gouvernement
pour immédiatement rejoindre une
institution financière
les remarquables félicitations à lui
c'est assez rare vous georges kuzmanovic
finalement le fait ces guéguerres
politiciennes en tout cas qui exaspère
quelque peu les français ils ne veulent
plus d'un d'un duel marine le pen et
emmanuel macron c'est ce que disent en
tout cas les sondages les sondages
disent aussi ce que les gens de droite
ne veulent plus voter pour emmanuel
macron comme ils l'auraient fait lors de
la précédente élection ses calculs
politiques exaspère les français ça
laisse le champ libre finalement à
d'autres candidats oui je pense
il ya une possibilité pour que émerge un
candidat qui va défendre les intérêts
souverains de la france et les intérêts
d'un peuple souverain on sait pas encore
qui ce sera mais on voit bien qu'il y à
quelque chose qui est en train de se
construire à gauche comme à droite
autour de cette question de souveraineté
j'aimerais souligner puisque vous
m'interrogez ce soir elle vous en
remercie tout cela fait suite à
l'article qui a été publié dans le
journal du dimanche dans ce journal du
dimanche
monsieur macro on veut élargir sa
majorité
il montre bien que sa majorité un
problème et donc des cherche à
phagocyter d'autres éléments encore une
fois cherche un poste ministériel est
derrière tout cela on à l'argument qui
était déjà dit lors de la presse dans
l'élection présidentielle que ces
gens-là représenterait un sorte de
centre dont quelque chose qui est ni
gauche ni droite
quelque chose qui au milieu qui est
paisible et apaisée en fait je tiens à
préciser que ces gens sont des
extrémistes
certains ont mis les extrémistes rues du
centre non ce sont des extrémistes de de
la perte plus forte ce sont des
extrémistes de l'affaiblissement d'état
ce sont des extrémistes de la
destruction des services publics et bien
évidemment nous sommes nombreux à
espérer qu'il aura une force politique
ou une coalition de forces politiques
qui vont émerger pour défendre la
souveraineté de la france et les
intérêts des français bien évidemment
impliquant la défense ve république
sociale merci georges
vite on a encore vingt mois évidemment
pour affiner cette analyse merci en tout
cas d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur
rt france